new zealand's nelson
tasman region is the home of sunny
beaches outrageous landscapes
and nelson a small city that boasts a
thriving art scene
craft breweries and wineries and a
farmer's market famed
for its local specialties
national geographic sent my colleagues
and me to explore the area
and tell its story
photographer erica larson visited the
beautiful abel tasman national park
to take a hike and a kayak trip with
local
guide leanne jacob
[Music]
welcome to the april tesla thank you
thanks for having me yeah
i wanted to meet you here because of
this beautiful view
looking over tipoketia
this is where we're going to start our
kayaking today
oh it's amazing the colors are beautiful
we've got a granite coastline and in
granite there's iron and so the iron
corrodes with the salt water and creates
the orangey colour
it's really accessible for all kinds of
people you don't have to be
really fit and climb mountains people
can
kayak or you can walk we've got
beautiful campsites right along the abel
tasman
so it's a park that you can really take
it at your own pace whatever that is
what is that yeah
we have a word in our culture manaki
tangra
and that means uh how we look after
people
so it gives us great mana it uplifts us
when we
look after people in the best possible
way all right
let's go kayaking yes i can't wait
[Music]
so this is split apple rock toka
is the maori name tuka means rock
and gnar means to burst or split
we know that 400 years ago the rock was
already split
but at one stage it would have been a
complete boulder
everyone entering the able tasman
generally will come
by here so it's that well known it's
like the gateway
just over an hour away from abel tasman
i went to explore nelson's
famous market and what i found blew me
[Applause]
[Music]
away
[Applause]
[Music]
hi hello this looks fantastic
very passionate about real ingredients
and the health benefits of it
oh wow that's really good yeah it's a
bit addictive
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
triple queen breed with a line of shaved
black truffles
oh my god crispy outside inside mr moist
and warm
okay and they make you very happy
temporarily
i'm here with pick from pix peanut
butter and pick i want to learn all
about
why this peanut butter is so special i
keep hearing all about it well i didn't
i didn't realize it was special i just
made some peanut butter because i got
crossed with buying peanut butter that's
full of sugar
and i made peanut butter at home and it
tasted nice we actually started selling
it here at this market
yeah but it wasn't until i i took it
overseas to america that i realized that
um
that it was uh special i can tell that
this is a community that likes to start
new things
it is it's a wonderful market i know
that for a lot of people new zealand is
high on the bucket list yeah no a lot of
people say you know they say that
new zealand's on my bucket list and i
say look there's no point in having
any other list just get down here
because i know they're going to love it
i don't know why the world doesn't live
meanwhile near nelson artist and author
christoph niemann visited renowned
local potter katie gold at her home
studio
hi nice to meet you nice to meet you too
so we're at your home and at your
workplace and at your gallery
well we live here and work here work
from home my husband and i
i use slabs of clay and i build things
up
make mostly vessels tell me a little bit
about the process
a lot of people have seen my work before
they're wanting something representing
part of new zealand where they live we
look at other pieces i've made
and then we turn that into a piece of
work for them
ones like this i have put the map of new
zealand so this is the old
captain cook's map screen printed on so
that's when new zealand was spelt
without an
a this piece here zaputakawa which is
the new zealand christmas tree
that flowers every december and new
zealand
would you like to come and see where i
would love to see the studio okay great
peace
take a little bit of clay roll it into a
ball
and then you pop it in to a little mold
and pop it out and you have the shell
so with all the shells i then turn them
into
these little bowls and these can hang on
the wall as well
this is for a f auction but it's got all
the paper roads and the maps and the
flaxes and what you'll see on the coast
of nelson
yeah from our trip we felt a lot it was
about the connection from
land to sea and it's beautiful how it
all comes together again
in the sculpture so the nelson region
is full of creative people and we love
sharing it with visitors who come here
especially if they give it a go as well
this has been a huge privilege
our journey ended at new door vineyards
where we met
rosie finn
now this is nice
so mum and dad still live on the
property their house is just on the
other side of those buildings
they planted the vineyard in 1978 and
did their first vintage in 1981. these
are the vineyards that your parents
planted
yep this is all of the original planting
so some of these well these are some of
the oldest chardonnay vines in the south
island
there's a lot of respect for the soil in
the land and where we are
it seems like nelson is the kind of
place that has lots of crafts and
artisans
am i right about that yeah absolutely i
think nelson's always had
an abundance of creativity this area in
particular you've got potters and
cider makers and olive oil and there's a
lot of inspiration in the land you've
got the able tasman this way and the
nelson lakes that way so
it's one of those areas where it's
pretty hard not to be inspired i think
cheers to that
the nelson tasman region is truly
magical
the people we met the warm welcomes we
received
the natural beauty we discovered it's a
place to find inspiration a place where
art
and craftsmanship natural wonder
and food and drink come together to
create a culture of personal connection
you